[музыка]
добрый день друзья мы находимся в козла
рве сегодня мы стартуем и начиная нашу
экспедицию от моря до моря
сегодняшняя наша задача собраться здесь
по и выехать на озеро камысты бас это
около 300 50 400 километров приаралье
там и обеды садимся на баги под туда
стартуем в сторону к королевской плотины
дальше мы переезжаем на большой орал и
по пустыне по устюрт у мы переезжаем
вроде башира и дальше двигаемся по у
стерта вот такой вкратце план наша цель
если бы враг общую цель то проехать от
аральского моря до каспийского моря вот
эта основная цель поэтому экспедиция
называется от моря до моря надеемся мы
благополучно завершим нашу экспедицию в
актау и до встречи там
баги тур это не столько путешествие
просто это еще другой вид обучение
просто побитую называется серия
переосмысление когда человек при моей
поддержке при поддержке матроса люд
самое главное при поддержке природы и
баги потому что когда человек видит сама
природа навевает на философские мысли на
переосмысление я это называю природа ты
лучше аудитория который лучше всего
учиться когда ты едешь не у тебя голова
не просто там пеший кайфуешь это не
развлекательно путешествие у нас значит
завтра 8 выезд 8 уже выезд то есть мы 80
о своих поел и выезжая нам ехать
догорала
победы там потом садимся на баги едем на
базе полдня пути
[музыка]
меня сегодня
первый раз просил часто единицы паги
именно из за этого и по если на балхаш
лесу вокале и чем ниже
вот сейчас я участвую качестве трекера и
так это у нас все продукты платформе
имеет образовательный характер и
это поездка тоже наносит достаточно так
погружение то есть и каждый участник он
должен погрузиться свои мысли свои
размышления от мы сегодня планируем
проехать около ста километров сегодня
какой учебно-тренировочном
[музыка]
я
зато свет видимся с руках
[музыка]
сегодня первый день подходит концу уже
утром и 8 трактор становится выехали
сказал д
доехали до места сбора там прошли
инструктаж методом жеребьевки выбраны
баги и
селе баги и ехали них они ехали
интересно очень было сегодня это только
первый день
следующие демон покажу что будет я думаю
будет еще выше
[музыка]
здравствуйте 1 2
полина палатки очень супер молотка очень
хорошая
прям как дома человек очень много
понимать через тело транспорт ощутив это
на себе там пару мыслей таких танца и
пересесть по вчерашнему для себя
зафиксировать сегодняшний день у нас это
деньги вспоминая детство но вот он я еще
еще очень важно ведь когда у сына это
все приятный момент потому что для того
чтобы библиотеку держать
и графика воспоминая она работает тогда
когда периодически вы карточки берете
смотрите на место старых берете смотрит
на место ставить то есть чтобы ваша
картотека была активной помните я
говорил что в течение жизни главное
задача человек это набрать библиотеку
воспоминания
сегодняшняя задача это детство и
сегодняшнего дня начинаем вечером и
типа вот таких вопросов что
примечательного увидел в природе чтоб
понравилось это то обязательно сегодня
вечером мы как раз будем
обсуждать каждый должен высказать
[музыка]
виды прекрасны
много мыслей различных приходит печально
что орал как высох своими глазами
мировые сми я бы твердят ученые axara
[музыка]
вчера как-то
первый раз за чьи-то что стрёмно не
первый раз до меня но местность
адаптация немножко другого сегодня
как-то раз своей фаррелл когда все
комфортно то будет уже чувствуешь машину
дорогу
[музыка]
вы предмет
уже по сторонам смотришь для меня это
все ново и воды был приятно удивлён
увидел коров здесь чем здесь как бы
питаться кармическое ладно верблюды я
ожидал сегодня черепаху мы встретили вот
вот это вот что жизненно есть везде вояк
классно будет машину
честно я не то что я когда увидел честно
какого ораву так как так можно как то
завтра у нас самый тяжелый день на ночь
контракт 370 380
маршрут надо для этого сегодня пораньше
лечь
616 2 проще и короче всем надо выезжать
за
[музыка]
сегодняшняя тема смотрите у нас деньги и
карьера и
большинства людей это понимает таким
образом слово то есть как нужно
зарабатывать все такое да но ошибка
заключается в том что многие думают что
счастье этого как раз таки успех деньги
и карьера гонится всю жизнь гонится за
этим погоне за бывает остальные другие
сферы своей жизни и в конце жизни
приходит тому что большое количество
расскажем в других моментов упущены для
того чтобы этого не было знаете есть
такая
хорошая итальянская пословица которая
говорит о том что и король и пешка после
игры идут в одну коробку
[музыка]
если бы вам стало известно что вы
никогда не будете богатым и известным
чтобы вы делали чем бы вы занимались
если бы вам сказать что нужно будет
заниматься только одним делом то чем бы
вы занимались и
вот решили перестанут перевернулись
не скажу что сильно так аккуратно были я
хотя какую себя
[музыка]
и
мы сейчас находимся
60 километрах юго-западнее поселка by
new это прямо середина устюрта сегодня
мы проехали 300 метров 12 часов ехали
ехали ехали наконец-то доехали к колесу
сделали вообще шикарно получилось
едет все нормально хорошо едем дождик
никогда в своей жизни по дождик на
богинь попадал сегодня 20 собирался
[музыка]
а ему сегодня долго ехали
340 километров очень интересным
приключением h1 баги перевернулся на это
было чисто нечаянно но дай бог все
нормально никто не пострадал все живы
здоровы и также уж его нету
[музыка]
я размышляла пришел в такой форме
эликсир жизни
эликсир жизни и такой эликсир которые вы
можете полить что угодно подберете
liksys хотите улучшить отношения с
другом эликсиром полете у вас отношение
будет просто шикарно хотите отношении
женой улучшить полете этим эликсиром
будет шикарно отношений хотите в бизнес
улучшить элексиром полете шикарный
близнецы как математическая под эликсир
жизни овнов сколько открывается
время
плюс энергия
скобка закрывается у можно любить
[музыка]
генератором показ сведение до игр
вологжан давали состав состоят в жопу
[музыка]
лучшим мы написали
интересных тебе
не должны быть такими очевидными должны
сами такими немножко
особенными которые знаем только мы
никому не рассказывали и вот организатор
прочитает это эти факты и я часики
должно будет кто это свадьба состоялась
2003 году и
в этом году я знаю я немного
света и рыбалка живые существa как я
я думаю что
года
[музыка]
[смех]
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
3 самых священных местах ходит это место
и вот не повезло здесь помолиться
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
я не ожидал увидеть такую красоту честно
говоря мне уже неделю под метелью четыре
дня едем а степей вот и такое такой
контраст
я одеял dillon
[музыка]
я краситель на нем кантату хотя бы так
хотел быть либо кто-то хотел бы ты
короля хотел бы там ученым они могут
отменили лизинга там
ну как жизни бывает выше цели вот
сегодня одна цель и
и астана корректируем да вот
по жизни до идем овцы коль на это это
это это то какой то тут в комментах он
там это мне не туда идем толчок был
хоть всякие мысли мы идем внутрь у
воинов проблемой маркетинг есть такое
правило чем меньше цена товара тем
больше
чем меньше цена товара . я вот для
примера скажу у меня все курсы дорогие и
очень дорогие то
есть в украину очень готовил этот того
как он рос у
него подписчиков там в разы больше чем у
меня но при этом
вперед все один доллар в месяц
грации
всего 12 долларов в год и знаете что у
него 30 процентов требует возврата
30 процентов людей требуют возврата от
12 долларов
[музыка]
собираемся подняться на вот эту самую
высшую точку придбати ра и
оттуда пофотографироваться там оттуда
шикарные виды поэтому вот всех гостей
хочу сводить тебя
на улице жара конечно
что поделаешь работа не выбирает
у страшного
крутовато для достигших людей
не такая привычная как как охотник мы по
горам розовой
поэтому для меня это
нормально так мы же не в гору поднимаюсь
это мы просто съехали в низину а сейчас
поднимаемся на уровне
поэтому я равнинный человек лишь опять 3
blues кроме
меня было 3
подняться на кожу рук вместе с марго
крича сыграть на к базе
[музыка]
волшебно особенно такие слои я раньше
думал что тирамису это пироженка такая
вкусно кажется это название горы
великолепная гора
[музыка]
с 2016 года магистерская августа такого
дождя не было вот местная говоря наш наш
привет это баракат и признана но
получается так скоро урожая пойдет
хорошо
все отлично и телефон нашёл свой я
потерял его воде без них он исходил а
вот судьба ги сломался мой когда
разбирает длились оказался
самое самое интересное это целиком
потерялся во втором багета закатился
туда под тройной слой чего-то там
посредине где-то все и вам какой-то
брюки и в этот момент у дороги у нас
ломается
плохо мы его не могли завести потом
попросили реагируем пошел там все
разворотил там все разворотил и просто
попутно нашел его телефон там прыскает
грязь всё идёт всё так на сегодня очень
хороший день по все
[музыка]
я жду
жеребьевка
ланс создавайте
погоди погоди я со мной природа по ходу
с нами шутки grade
когда в сухую одеваемся ливень идет это
подготовили скребли солнце
красиво красиво
каждый энписи
их пачкал матрацы и
пачка баги матрас и поэтому ему а денег
у него смотрите вот попить больше не
опасным страшным местам вот не
выдерживает
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
здесь всего семь дней
7 дней выжимаем что есть новый баскин
развитие
это когда за рулем простоишь party
хватало лишь из остановились круг на
землю уже и сам прошел
[музыка]
уже к правила по
всем ты малыш комбо чтобы нарисовать
чем моложе ты лучше буду рисковать
потому что внизу и заработать на риск и
соответственно
несколько
тем более
такой не
слышал ни одного богатого человека
которая полна зато на из-за того что
бежал всю жизнь едина виды во время
системного кризиса меняется система
во время рыночного креста система не
меняет идет просто
рэй балансировка а системный кризис
когда советский союз распался
этой системой все изменился систем
[музыка]
мы сейчас решили ехать по маршруту
жесткий living впервые за шесть лет в
акта уйдет такой дождь это просто
неимоверно и
ребята решили ночевать попросили
ночевать даси из и но взамен мы весь
маршрут будет грязь месить все по готова
на все уходит вперед
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
что очень рад что наконец-то я все
больше и больше значит я знаю соседа
казахстана и не больше и больше нравится
начинает нравиться не то что
казахстанскую земли людей еще больше
начинают там вот по характеру наверное
ли там по каким-то ментальным
соображением нервы ближе нам чем
кто-либо другой
[музыка]
мы находимся в местность жалко там моя
каспийское море и добрались до 2 боли от
российского
экспедиция от моря до моря будет
возможность хочу приехать сюда со своей
семьей хочу чтобы мои действия video
game ты на красивые
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
то что я сюда приехал это очень важное
решение меня зовут онлайн я из астаны
адвокат меня зовут адильхан
я занимаюсь недвижимостью
я и моя команда создаем самые красивые
чистые и безопасно пишите в данный
момент в голове вот три вещи первая
стандартизировать свою жизнь второе
стандартизировать бизнес третье
поставить цель и планы на будущее или
новым годом время свободное было и мы
накупили женой обладала включён
телевизор и
зашли в телевизор там спорта в youtube
думаю ночью не познает полезное ну да мы
вам количество снова появилась и симбой
написал опрос по и скидки могу вам
системой и мне вот первая вышла поездка
от моря до моря я включила ее
[музыка]
из самого начала там началось интервью
там показывают ребят
сервисмены потом количестве с одним
столом я угроза их сразу интересно очень
очень интересно и
я и тогда и что ж не дай бог я тоже
поеду под экспедиция в первую очередь
выйти из зоны комфорта покататься на
баги в степи на западе я в первый раз
был в козла ради в актау условия такие
были немножко где-то спартанские условия
в в мощной команде и познакомиться с
новыми людьми
посидит правит проводить вечера безо
кострами обсуждениями с маргулан к ливии
чем
[смех]
как говорится не сложно научиться новым
сложно отбросить стоит
если начинаю опускаться буду работать
можно ли социум на то что ты тебя уже в
принципе не судят мы
[музыка]
желание радиации что очень немаловажно
меня дела не то что я более покататься
дела в команде дело единомышленники там
дело совсем другой уровень здесь совсем
другое я об это вообще не жалею мне
очень понравилась больше всего мне
понравилась наша финальная локация
это мыслю к рогам
на мой экран находится маяк
который построен не знаю куда мы его
ночью старый это видно он сделан из
камней это же просто камни которые
следует на глиной для меня большим таким
даже не может быть это дни сайтом
каким-то осознанием этот выход из зоны
комфорта в такой мощной команде это вот
есть пользы получил я больше чем ожидал
но оно пришло не сразу это все
постепенно и вот кто ищет он идет я
искал пользу я его нашел я искал столько
получил столько
[музыка]